of them doing at the the queen 87
they're both the same but i visually
it's always nice to you know 20 seconds
this is good he's making moves he's
going to show us the checkmate hopefully
he doesn't resign we want to see the
checkmate on the board the other game we
can understand the resignation it would
have gone on a while but the result was
inevitable but here
yeah it's just bringing the white rook
over to the h1 square lining it up
behind the white queen and
checkmate is coming in the next two
moves can you even prevent it it's force
checkmate maybe you can give up your
queen but uh it's force checkmate i'd
love to see it maybe he heard us maybe
we're going to be lovely to see a
checkmate on the board i don't know how
many times ah
disappointing there no checkmate on the
board but a win for magnus carlsen he
makes a comeback he is tied now in the
match with liam lee one more game to
play in the rapid
portion
but it's uh well it's dramatic in
another game going on in the oslo arena
magnus heading